VP they need this they need the agus as
well as the cheese if they can have any
chance against lfy being to racks down
against him and it looks like for the
Marmot rolling ball to offer was the
beacon be preempted he tried to give the
jump he found a black ball and it also
gave me an inch at the deficit finish
evolve enjoy come through the
[Applause]
shape-shift down for 25 seconds I think
without the shade ship and the Ricky
they have no way to stick on gh gh s the
most important here right now in fact
it's gonna be Rincon jumping in they
the thanking icebox coming in and then
founded back in JH would be out you
once again marching in how do they take
this bike easy will
finally have study genie
Oh
now their body the genomic kind of
initiation clearly of color goes up
there with the NSA to dominate the tabs
you got you finesse key they pull the
rabbit out of the Hat
vici gaming start to outplay VP down the
stretch here and now they've got them on
the run they damage the one they chase
forward Archie gaze there
big game a doors
and cut some of the dads jumping forward
but a beautiful cause by mrs. prevents
the universe initiation porcina back
he's automata they don't have a tool for
this fight NPCs opportunity rushing in
spotted there as well there's the chance
though followed this yet but lightning
light is going to force down but where's
your detection he finds under the gloom
Akane they know he's dead
burners beer it separates up the fight
he comes your eyes loss his all can do
is still getting the quilt brains out
the damage output however the became me
is the only thing protecting him the
physical damage rebutting finally able
to get through the BIR Tawil walls are
full and bigness gaming of long-term
mods Bank on separate dump with the road
fight
somebody killed ribbon here comes didn't
see though I can liquid on the high
ground they have that vision they move
in sandwich gets a nice done on the to
the follow-up they're rapin goes to work
triple kill for oh my god it is batted
down liquid they can't really challenge
and they basically just gave away the
roche up bed is he trying to make this
feel Shiva scarf giving vision he jumps
right in sonic wave again against the
ages by back on the refresher for our
bed a Superman right now
now that the talent is gone they know
that it's going to be no TP backup so
immediately came the closes in Lord lay
and now burning he's come home
the standstill hold your breath and hope
for the best play do they do they have a
plan B of slowing it down trying to go
Lane a miracle doesn't wanna let them
get there anyway he jumps in fine CDC
three shots and disrupt her down and
crating through the way if they chase
for more they back in play back in dad
dies oh they do Scott this out though it
is nighttime can secret make a play here
without the illuminate he'll this is
where Luther can be strongest but mayor
Cole is hammering this roach down
quickly if he moves anyone support the
[Music]
bees down secret art samples now miracle
chasing forward through your phone
that's a double die back to eg is coming
they smoked up SG will go inside the he
will as of yet although several members
of liquid are very low and kuroky
getting right click forced to pop the
supernova they're able to jump in they
find it going to gh there's the ravage
counter play though is it going to be
enough they're able to find it so much
damage miracle cousin is well dominating
for him oh lordy more the ravage wasn't
going to be enough to say that hang that
egg was still going now it was Sunday I
couldn't go the magic fan doesn't again
things forward knowing that he wants to
get something out this BKB to be Timmy
we're gonna go stick and a black hole to
great black hole from him to storm that
dire observer would see so much the jump
for the summer for all burning with a
whole top as well they need to kill the
ball may not be faithful create space
but in to the all meet match therapy bow
lose everything
this place looks horrible the split gets
torn apart as well aha me taking a pot
the brewmaster resolution and no detail
now completely alone they'll deal with
Victoria first no ticket so those two
heroes done here can resolution fight
his way out of this one he's disarmed
for span he may be able to kill him off
with this done
you betcha he's gonna kill the Sven he's
completely alone in a 103 he is a rapist
he's gonna go for Equinix that clean oh
he doesn't get the clean after I just
seen there in this gonna try to eat me
out no breathe fire
look at my sticks around baby gonna play
him he's got solder and he may be others
done someone can't son save you the law
turns around he goes for the hog burger
Magi instead he has been silenced up
Victoria really doing all too well and
now no Katie sees FY who's gonna go for
FY sprouts himself spring keeps alive
resolutions come but he's gonna kill
another resolution you madman he's
absolutely destroying them he's 1 vs. 4
he's got himself a triple kill all alone
he's got enough for Heroes he don't
hungry for them looking for Buffy puppy
can he get his way out of this yet no
quite level 6 unless you turned he's
gonna kill the disruptor yaps who's
gonna get another kill out of this one
as he taped disrupter down he'll steal
the Dragons say he can turn around and
you come down gonna lose his straight
back picks up another track steered
toward the town for the fateful
brixon yep so sometimes oh my god yeah
we've got absolutely shredded NP though
try their best they're all you come down
the juggernaut now out of the spite to
what heroes seeping forward our TV looks
like you've in it for the long haul Jack
the infant gets the crush of the two and
there's a sonic wave to vacuum it into
the Phoenix oats isn't going to be
enough to turn this fight but no eg
still coming out victorious
RVT it was just a scratch of home
secures a rampage at 14 minutes in last
be speaking of practice
quick jump old with multiple spirits
avail plans to kill an aesthete if fate
punishing however keeping the chase
going he has good survival the vision is
not to fail now being pulled back up the
Talbot speaking Zicam charged that is
exactly what's happened we go for the
smoke gank sign just wants to farm a
wave and he will plink out of time but
still puppy gets enraged for the never
sick tomorrow
that's him out to safety the aged were
attacking him and they found the fellow
what they got me know of month they need
to bring it down before we can toes of
the black hole because the hall
so I jumped into a toddler to pick up
his bass he doesn't get it off in time
the enigma will fall the Terra played in
the mids of this fight trying to pump
out the damage the crystal maiden County
was more Universal company t-midi -
t-midi doing it at teen suicide will so
in the neighborhood to try making play
there's done basic laptop lay Marion
Goll friends is trying to go for Fonda
with that mana burn the boat of this
size it's not gonna get the chance to
get out those days or is he the time
comes in is the forward them BP they
have tobacco cloud9 have taken one
they've taken two outside apology but
I'll sound somebody quit a pan here come
the auto attacks you're gonna set up
with Nicole - well no but the flush out
from chair act comes through once again
he's on top of the pledge of the earth
Ben allows us to listen to come with a
sonic wave he'll back up the fall and
now face us boys get in a profit most
likely AZ loft Meatwad however knowing
is just alive enough for it now at the
top okay two seconds it doesn't matter
the scream comes out he goes down double
kill for resolution on the solo pretty
dream a decision here warlock almost
dead the four step though keep him alive
Fresno commits forward into this they
exit back from on to get the horn
do they have the tendons to kill up
resolution they kind of make control of
they tore it him down but the Curtis
field will make up for it and they bring
down miracles that miss Brittany has to
go right as we get to relocate it out io
g8 there to save the day the buyback
coming in
old eleven packs all supervisor yeah
otherwise department but making sure
ta trying to tender his way out with men
did he fly out and he TP borrowed GH
what make one's gonna rape here got
ready to fly finally they've got the hex
defensive disruption buying time to
protect miracle from the static storm
those took a list on the 45 America gets
the beak heavy on time
transport father ace backing off as he
became he's loose to retrieve us better
catch in America but it's not enough
damage look the damage discharged who
saw his father fought about the
refreshment he has no matter we will get
the double kill the type regains too
much he's still full out move on he's
looking for the troll again the tyria
cut through triple kill from upon gh
will buy back the absolute the vision
onto mind-control they claim themselves
are four and they do anything here
liquid with three heroes downward to the
mound with buyback available ace does
get picked off by the bear metamer man
finds one miracle surrounded all
tricular fiberboard
this rapier doing so much work in this
teamfight
right now th she's gonna get the cover
is it he just walks
he just gives it away and in fact cement
may be in trouble
unity predicts his movement miracle just
used his in this field so much like mate
movie feels at sir nailing it's a
miracle they're not committing to
heavily and with a venomous memory me
has that BKB to react to talks was all
about miracle Department akka you know
can I follow up Fishman KP he'll get the
son of the man across the middle of
build us a new car
if I kill khakha
but take a drum thing prepare me
liquid art so close it was what Margaret
fight they know there can't be
newbies line up they must have
any big pill
they see everything here comes the echo
slam who is it gonna be enough or not
yet the pitcher is out never control is
an eyes-only from Muji maybe the
regeneration of miracle the agency mode
will Punk faith in the shackle in
forever holding him
[Applause]
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]